hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and
i'm just checking in on you
i'm just checking to see
how you're doing i hope you're doing
great how about that there's something
nice
i don't care what color tie you're
wearing
oh wait a minute happy insurrection
anniversary day
aka the keg party gone wrong
jesus christ man they're [ __ ] putting
the screws to those people
people getting four years five years
you know
i don't know
what do you you know i got to be honest
with you
if you're going to keep your own people
that's stupid you can't get upset that
every once in a while they're going to
storm the castle
all right i think we should have taken
as americans
we should have taken a long hard look
at the the stupidity that had gathered
and all agreed with one another
and realized that we really need to put
more funds into public schools or
whatever
we need people to have you know
they need to be more learned
you know what i'm saying dude
um
yeah that was just a sea of idiots and
regardless of political beliefs before
people think that this is going to be
some
oh billy [ __ ] blue bra hollywood
lefty leaning thing
i don't like the extreme left either oh
look at you bill oh you're one of those
guys who says he's right down the middle
i am
right up your [ __ ] ass right down the
middle
[Music]
um
that's if i was the judge i just want to
talk to you know some of those people
they got all the way in there
that was a funny thing they didn't think
they were going to get that far and then
they got they got all the way in there
they're sitting at the desks
of the people that they didn't like that
they wanted to talk to they didn't know
what to do
that was like the joker
i'm a dog chasing a car i wouldn't know
what to do if i caught it
that's what happened to him then they
sat at the desk they're like
america
just started tipping over stuff and
smearing [ __ ] on the wall they literally
acted like a bunch of animals that got
out of a [ __ ] zoo
man that would be the [ __ ] to be the
judge on one of those
i'd act like i was presiding and doing
all that but really i'd be trying to get
all kinds of inside scoop you know i'd
just be like
hey for real like
like what were you thinking
like how far did you like
how far ahead would you think were you
just like
in a zone
like a dumb person's own right foot and
now left foot and a right foot keep
walking towards that thing that i'm mad
at
um
you know
i don't know
all i can say is thank god they were you
know for the most part they were all
white people so
they won't be in jail long
[Music]
[Laughter]
um
anyway
you know i don't want to sit there and
trash them the whole time but i got to
say they they [ __ ] got real close
they got real close they just picked the
wrong century
if they got that far in the 17 or 1800s
well 1700s it wouldn't have been there
i don't know how we built the capitol
the 1800s if they got that far they
would have been running [ __ ] for at
least the afternoon
a couple of days
before people showed up with [ __ ]
muskets and stuff
uh but that was back then when you could
fight people off
it was a lot easier back then to
overthrow a government you know what i
mean
all you needed was a couple of your deer
hunting friends
and a good plan
a little ted offensive
redneck style you could go right in
there you could do it
can't do that anymore
the technology is too good which is why
i always crack up when i hear
gun people say hey they want their guns
you know come and get them it's just
like all right well you know
we don't want to kill you but you know
we have the technology to have a nerd
who can't even do a pull-up three states
away fly a drone over to your house and
vaporize you while you're eating frito
dip before you even know you're under
attack i mean we could do that
if we chose
there's one upside to all of this you
know if those people actually succeeded
if you could block out the confederate
flag on the money
that guy with the buffalo head would
look pretty good you know right down the
middle
i mean if i was like a tourist they'd be
like hey man you know
this country seems already [ __ ]
people get after it
um
i wonder how many chicks that guy met
shirtless you know buffalo head american
flag
you know to a lot of women that guy was
a hero
you know maybe not women that you know
whether you choose to associate with
or maybe you know maybe you do maybe you
took a picture with one of them
and eight people on twitter got upset
and then all of a sudden apologies had
to be issued what in the [ __ ] are we
doing by the way
with all of this crap i just don't
understand any of it
are you i owe you an apology because you
don't like my friend
[Music]
it's [ __ ] seventh grade
bill i think you're over simplifying the
issue am i
well that's what my brain does it overly
simplifies things so i don't get
overwhelmed do you ever think about that
maybe i need to dumb things down in my
mind
so i could get my [ __ ] head around it
um anyway i am actually uh taking the
[ __ ] from today for the rest of the
weekend
off i ain't doing [ __ ]
i've been working my ass off
right through the freaking holidays and
i have a little four-day window oh bill
what are you gonna do oh i'll tell you
what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna get a little fire pit going
i'm gonna watch the bruins i haven't
watched the bruins in like two months
i know we're doing all right we got a
[ __ ] three-game winning streak
playing 600 ball here we got the
minnesota wild
um
terrible name
beautiful third jersey great arena
incredible fans
they were the [ __ ] north stars
they should have been able to keep that
name the way the cleveland brown fans at
least kept
the name the cleveland browns
the dallas stars i guess it kind of
makes sense
cowboys have a star
right dallas star
the lone star state
you know people in dallas
are like country western famous is how
they carry themselves
you know
you ever see a cowboy with botox
that's dallas
[Music]
[Laughter]
if you ever wonder what the cast of
bonanza would look like with frozen face
that is dallas texas
it isn't but it's a funny image um
dallas actually might be my favorite
city
in texas
i used to [ __ ] hate houston and i
think it was because i always went there
in the summertime and it was just
[ __ ] like melt the bottom of your
shoes hot
um
in fact i remember i went to a game at
the astrodome one of the last years they
had it
um
and i just remember walking across that
parking lot and i could feel like but
the bottom of my feet was so [ __ ] hot
it was just oh it was a brutal day
brutal day and i was walking in the dome
like this place better have ac because
they were about ready to tear it down
you know that is you're going to tear
something down if the air conditioning
starts leaking you're not going to fix
it
but uh i went in there and um
had a great time a lot of interesting
trivia who hit the first home run at the
houston astrodome
mickey mantle
late in his career to me that kind of
signaled like uh
a transition to errors it had to have
been to see mickey mantle play in that
place
after playing in uh original yankee
stadium
the not the house that ruth built the
house that they built for babe ruth
um with a [ __ ] two-foot right field
uh
fence
i have to find that picture that
original fence if you backed up to catch
a fly ball it would have hit you right
behind your knees and you would have
fell into the front row
um but that's when fans used to behave
themselves
did they i don't even know i don't know
what they did back then it all depends
on like who you talk to and some of the
[ __ ] that you read about
it's like that's been although people
were better back then it's like okay but
i also saw that movie gangs in new york
you know
which then you know out of that [ __ ]
came more organized crime
and that whole [ __ ] error
i don't know
and all the you know what it is it all
depends on what part of the world you're
looking into you appear into when you go
in the back
you go back in into the past to say
which is you know it was a simpler time
no your life was simpler
you know like to me the good old days is
the 70s and 80s but anyone who was an
adult those were not good times
crack 80s
cocaine the big lie
right
[ __ ] uh
what is it uh the 70s who the [ __ ] is
the hell it's my wife jesus christ that
just scared the [ __ ] out of me had the
[ __ ] window open i saw somebody walk
by my peripheral
that's that's that's the length of my
self-defense
who the [ __ ] is that
i'm a serial killer oh nice to meet you
end of my life open in her ears with
that sound effect sorry i never claimed
to be michael winslow
i can't do the sound of a chainsaw
um
anyway yeah i'm taking a little [ __ ]
couple of days
off gonna enjoy myself here you know
uh and i'm doing that a couple times
this year
so i don't get uh suicidal
not really suicidal but you know and
then you just think of that [ __ ]
you just start thinking of death as a
release
like it's got to be amazing
to die
if you have all of this work in front of
you and just crushing debt
you know when you're laying there and
the dopamine is kicking in
i i would think that like it's like the
the dopamine kicking in combined with no
more debt or [ __ ] stress at work is
like doing like a speed ball
that's the emotional heroin and cocaine
what am i talking about
stop glamorizing
um
i'm not i'm talking about mental health
issues people that's what i'm discussing
um
you know i didn't speaking of that i
didn't see what that guy antonio brown i
didn't see what his statement was
but uh yeah that looked like a manic
episode
[ __ ] unreal man people need help
we used to [ __ ] did we used to help
him i don't know what the [ __ ] we did
all i know is we just sort of let all
[ __ ] people out on the street
they used to have uh
i don't know maybe they have them did it
all get privatized
you know this is what i do i bring up
big topics and then i don't have any
information then i ask you guys
questions like you can answer me
that's how i do it
that is how i do it so i'm [ __ ]
chilling out here i'm gonna sleep for
[ __ ] four days
and not do anything i'm gonna watch a
little bit of hockey that i'm gonna get
going again
that's how it is all right who do you
guys like monday night by the way
[Music]
crimson tide against the georgia
bulldogs
you know i don't know who to root for
on a football level i have to root for
georgia just because alabama has won so
much
but then as i was saying before
people in georgia
they look down on alabama
like they're not the same kind of stupid
you know it's like when i moved to new
york and i'd hear all these new yorkers
[ __ ] on new jersey it's like you
guys are all drinking under the same
[ __ ] tap water
no dude no i'm telling you it's
different it's different it isn't
it isn't all right they just didn't
write enough good songs about new jersey
all the good songwriters in new jersey
moved to new york and then blew new york
i wanna wake up
in a city
that doesn't sleep
[Music]
you know there's not a lot to write
about in new jersey
you know why
because it's it's [ __ ] relaxing
new jersey it has a lot of beautiful
parts to it you're going to new york and
everybody's [ __ ] at each other's
throats
you know
trying to get a bigger apartment
trying to angle in on something trying
to outbid somebody
going down there with that [ __ ]
[ __ ] if anybody could ever explain
to me what what wall street is
that's like the track for rich people
except it's it's got to be rigged
because rich people don't like losing
money
i remember when i was a kid i used to
watch that stock market ticker thing
thing going by with ticker tape whatever
[ __ ] you call it the stock ticker
whatever the hell that thing's called
i remember thinking like you know
someday i would like to actually have a
legitimate reaction to that thing
then i'll know that i actually have
money
and i'm doing well in life like i really
believed that for a while
you know and here i am 53 [ __ ] years
old i still look at i don't even know
what it means i know what it is it's
it's the different stocks and whether
they're up or down but i've never seen
anybody looking at it
other than at wall street and for some
stupid reason in new york they have it
on the outside of a number of buildings
and i have never seen anybody just
sitting there you know with their mouth
or gay like oh my god we're ruined
just never happened
sorry
having a little root beer here that's
all i got
okay
when i get excited
you know this is what this is what the
deal is in life there's partying before
you're 50 and then after
and partying after you're 50. let me
tell you what that involves
being excited about getting into bed at
8 30 at night
i do that a lot some might really don't
then i'm going down a [ __ ] rabbit
hole instead of going to sleep i gotta
get one of those [ __ ] michael jackson
masks
you know what i mean you sleep inside a
[ __ ] iron lung
you know you get some chimpanzee that
you trust to lock the thing and then
he's gonna wake up the next morning let
yin you're not gonna be liking that ex
martiana
you're banging on the inside of the
glass as the [ __ ] monkey puts on a
suit and walks out the door
expressionless look on its face
how great was that movie by the way
you know it was such a great movie i was
surprised that women's groups weren't
upset by that
that somehow they didn't catch the
metaphor
you know
this [ __ ] broad was banging both of
them
she [ __ ] kills them both
and takes off and i'm supposed to be
rooting for her oh good she's free
you just killed two people
you know why couldn't you just say
listen
you know talk to your owner
as a robot you just talk to your owner
and just say listen i'm not happy
okay it's not you it's me i just this
relationship isn't working out for me
all right
and i'm being nice about this because
i'm made out of titanium and if i wanted
to if i really wanted to
i could go upside your head
through whatever limb you try and block
and i could crush your [ __ ] skull
my wife just walked in on the end of
that
um
oh she has the ear buds in
that's one of the greatest things for a
marriage is earbuds
you know
you don't have to hear the sound of your
spouse's voice just driving you nuts in
a stupid podcast one room away
doing a bad frank sinatra
hey nia
i got to ask you a question
okay at this point in your life
hello
well you got to come closer to the
microphone for the people hanging on my
every word here boarding a southwest
flight can enjoy this
i took southwest where the hell was i
going
i went to arizona oh my god
[ __ ] joke machine on the microphone
it's like i get it they told you to use
humor
you don't have to start assaulting me
with your [ __ ] airline jokes all
right nia i got to ask you a question
that's how my audience feels come over
here if you're going to trash me
i said don't assault me with your comedy
she goes that's how your audience feels
come over here nia
the lovely nia everybody
sneaking in on the podcast since 2008
14 years nia you've been walking into
the room as the lovely nia i know and i
haven't been on in a while you haven't
it's almost like we had a couple of kids
and we don't have time for each other
anymore seriously well how you doing i'm
doing good here's my question for you
okay
at the age you're at now
gun to your head
why does it have to be gunned in my head
can you just ask me
all right my opinion
gun to your throat
slingshot to your ass
um new jersey
in a house with a yard and a pool
or a manhattan
uh
you know doorman building with a view
new jersey house with a pool told you
i've been trying to tell them that
there's a difference there's
partying
under 50 and over 50.
you know well i'm not 50 yet how old are
you again i'm under 50.
[Music]
i married a youngin people
i had to get a broad that was dumb
enough to not realize what she was
marrying
well
you accomplished that goal
i did
that's what i always say to you when you
get mad at me
you knew what you're my fault well you
knew what you were marrying
not fully
i feel like you don't really get to know
someone after you until you've lived
with them for a while how long do we
live together before we actually got
married we were together forever we were
basically married we met each other and
basically married two years in and i
give more information but it ends up on
the [ __ ] internet
on some creepy site here's all you need
to know i got to stop talking about that
we got to start putting out
misinformation that's true we met
yeah
i was a woman when nia first met me
what changes folks a lot of changes has
anybody ever transitioned
from a brunette woman
to a ginger male
do people turn into ginger males i don't
i you know transition to ginger i don't
know is that the correct terminology no
there's actually
this very hot transgendered porn star
who i feel like is kind of red headish
like has a red what [ __ ] world are
you in on the internet
no no he's hot i have to find it for you
so which way did the train go
it went from fema adam to eve or eve to
adam he's adam
yes
and i gotta say he's hot
he's like really muscular very sexy i'm
telling you
listen texts all kinds you know
oh that really annoyed that whole thing
annoyed me i'm trying to get into shape
and you're telling me that somebody who
was wasn't wasn't even a redhead
was a brunette wasn't even a man got it
transitioned it became in better shape
than me
well there were obviously some like
chemical factors that went into that but
you know
also i feel like a lot of protein shakes
and
egg whites oh you're saying hgh maybe i
don't know i don't know i'm all i'm
saying is the porn stars get drug tested
i don't know phil i don't know why
why are you interrogating me about this
because you didn't seem like a casual
fan of porn if you were that far into it
no
i saw him on some like
uh something on hbo something that
highlighted like trans people that was
like he was one of the people that they
profiled so that's how oh i'm watching
porn it wasn't the emmys no it wasn't
the emmys either
he said something that highlights trans
people
hollywood award shows and then the next
day conservative radio has a field day i
mean i'm trying to watch that show with
my children
hey to dry my child's eyes with a
confederate flag with what he saw
tonight
um two shots nia at the confederate flag
i admit i thought i think it's a cool
looking flag though are you wrapping up
it's not are you ready well back in the
day when i used to watch
when i used to watch the dukes of
hazards
yeah
how did you view that show i just used
just a couple of good old boys that was
not my generation it's a crazy cooter i
got you got your ears on come on
um that's what she said
um all right well
okay
it was nice talking to you
um
i'm surprised you know that 69 dodge
challenger isn't more expensive with the
amount of [ __ ] challenges that they
ruined on that [ __ ] show when they do
those slow motion jumps like the editing
on it you literally watch them bend the
frame so many [ __ ] times they
probably had stock footage after a while
i mean how many barns can you jump
through how about a shout out for the
stuntmen in their spinal their compacted
spinal cords
on all of those shows burt reynolds used
to do that
the guy was starring in the movie and
he'd still get in the car to [ __ ]
jump the goddamn lagoon
and like a [ __ ] 72 ford f you know
500 whatever the hell it's called the
ltd
um
that's back when they were men
not these people today with them airbags
um
all right well anyway i don't have any
advertising can you believe it
can you believe that what i talked about
today that there's not a whole bunch of
advertising trying to jump onto
the people that would sit and listen to
this
um
i'm so old right now i actually have my
legs crossed and i'm like moving my foot
for some stupid reason like at what
point do you get so old that this is
like comfortable i think just one of
your hips is so relieved that it doesn't
have weight on it
um
all right so i'm gonna watch the bruins
versus the minnesota wild
god that's they must have hated that
name when it first came out
how about the minnesota wilderness
minnesota wilden
yo they'd be wildin
you know
they could sign all the all the people
of color in the nhl
then they'd have to play in minnesota
all right that was a stupid idea all
right let's go i'm gonna you know what
by the end of the podcast i'm gonna come
up i'm gonna rename teams
that have shitty [ __ ] names
okay we're starting with
the minnesota wild
um
you know what i do like about teams in
florida is how many of them named after
like either weather or weather events
you know
the heat the lightning
all down south the hurricanes
right
when they got dolphins
that was a dumb one
that's just this one that's one of those
dumb team names it's just been around so
long that you don't notice
the dolphins
the [ __ ] and the sharks was available
they didn't go with that they weren't
the dolphins
and i know there's a bunch of nerves
actually a dolphin is a mammal and it's
a very highly intelligent oh yeah is
that why they keep getting caught and
going to sea world
you know
the smart criminals you don't even know
their names
if flipper was so goddamn [ __ ] smart
how did he get locked into that [ __ ]
awful contract in the 1960s no residuals
spouting the same line every goddamn
episode now jesus bill what are you
talking about i don't know
i don't know so i'm going to chill out
here for the next few days i highly
recommend it if you ever get a chance to
do it because i find that uh i come out
the other side
you know i'm a better parent
i can tolerate my wife a little more
now she went
downstairs is there anything better than
provoking a fight with your wife just to
do it
you know what i mean like sparring
and then you don't even care if you win
so you actually get in the pocket you
start destroying them in the argument
this is when you know you're beating a
woman in an argument
she just abandons the topic and just
goes what is your problem
no no no i just mean like overall
because they're trying to get it off the
topic that they're losing on now just
let's just expand this conversation
outwards just what exactly is your
problem
because i'll tell you i have noticed
they start talking real vague there's
just been an overall attitude changing
you over the last couple of weeks broad
brush
as you keep sitting there throwing darts
sweetheart there's no reason why
at the weight you're at
okay and you go to the gym
that you cannot pick up a garbage bag
tie it off and take it out back and put
it into a [ __ ]
trash can there's just no reason why you
can't do that
when did i become
the garbage man in the house
okay you fill up half the bag
and i'm being nice
all right
okay
fine you want me to take the [ __ ]
chance yeah
fat i take the [ __ ] chance yeah they
start taking it out and they start
crying
right
and then you got to be like oh no all
right forget it i'm sorry
i know you don't like doing it
you know what if i ever did a reboot of
the joker i just have him in a
relationship
and he'd win every argument
like in that moment will you cave
he would just start laughing
just exactly what is what is wrong with
you joker
what is going on with you
um
which came first the joker or the grinch
i feel like they're somehow related
you know
they both grew up in the same abusive
household
one chose isolation
the other chose to be alone with
everybody
that's stupid phrase right new york come
to new york and be alone with everybody
oh my god i love that i should put that
on a [ __ ] t-shirt
um all right that is the podcast
everybody here we go bruins here we go
i guess pasta had a big game yesterday a
couple days ago um so billy the jinx
is gonna be sitting down watching
they're in the middle of a three-game
win streak if i sit down and and they
lose you know what that means it's
because i was watching
that's how a sports fan thinks all right
that is it people we're going into the
final weekend
put it up week 18 of nfl football can
you believe it
absolutely insane and speaking of that
uh
we got the uh
the
the bet mg mg mgm mg it's a car bet mgm
segment of this week where me and paul
verzi have been going head-to-head you
picked four games against the spread now
like these softies on network tv you
just try to pick a on against the money
line we're actually going against the
spread and paul verzi and i are both
like five or six games over 500 four
games a week picking against the spread
you tell me another sports show out
there that's doing that there i'll tell
you right now there is one maybe there
is i don't know
i have no idea
you know
maybe dan katz over at barstool
he's got a sharp mind he's got a sharp
mind for the sports
he was raised right um all right listen
to the bet mgm uh
segment here with myself
and they always wonderful paul
what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better podcast nfl edition
uh sponsored by bet mgm and guys it is
sad to say but we are down to the last
regular season of the week i can't
believe how [ __ ] fast this uh this
this year is gone
i know but what an ending
we're not going to just do the picture
paul version
went three and one three and one as i'm
going two and two giving up the middle
of the field
trying to eat up the clock playing
you're in a preview
and i said to andrew last week i've got
yeah whatever i go if i win two games
this week guys should be all right
there's no way he's gonna he's due for a
bad week
paul versey goes out in week 16
4-0
the best three weeks of the season
with either one of us and i'm going to
say in all the professional as far as
these sports talk who else is picking
four games a week and over three weeks
goes ten and two against the spread
it's it's really listen man
after 17 weeks of pitting a picking
against the spread in the nfl okay
against the spread bill's record 37 29
and one
that means through every other year
because this is the only year that
they've added 18 games you're making
money and if and if both of us go 0 and
4 we beat the [ __ ] book we did it
it's in the books which i've never done
before
um so bill's 37 29 and one i mean uh 37
20 91 i'm 38 and and 30. we are going
into the last week
half a [ __ ] birthday and down the
stretch they come first he wailing on
his horse passes me on the outside
no no here's what it was i broke out of
the gate early and i had like a two
horse lead then you're gonna wave into
the crowd that's what you think you let
me catch up then you came around the
second turn and you went up by two
horses and everyone's like oh [ __ ] and
now we're at the last furlong
like this um but hey i think my horse is
out of gas paul
uh man listen
if i if if if i lose this week means
nothing it's like if the usa beat the
russians but then lost to finland
it does not great that's [ __ ] it
still meant something we wanted the gold
medal that'd be like if the red sox in
2004 the yankees we still we had you
could we still could have uh chanted uh
1918 as my [ __ ] internet's not
working god damn it i don't have these
spreads in front of me
all right let's go i think i know what i
want i think i know you want here who's
who goes first
so uh yeah let me just do this offer
real quick guys uh sorry
no no it's all good all right guys as
you know the anything better podcast has
teamed up with bet mgm the most reliable
name the most reliable lines in betting
and we've had such a good time with them
we're making picks for you guys we have
special offers for our listeners each
week if you haven't signed up for bad
mgm it's very simple uh use a bonus code
burr that's b-u-r-r you'll get 200
for free after placing your first ten
dollar bet here's how it works you
download the bet mgm app okay you sign
up use bonus code bur place your first
ten dollar money line bet any nfl game
you will receive 200 in free bets um
immediately after placing your bet
regardless of the outcome just make sure
you use bonus code burr burr when you
sign up they're giving you 200 to play
with have fun be responsible with it and
enjoy it like you have all year and hey
let's be honest if you've been listening
to anything better you've been making
some [ __ ] dough can we be honest we
could talk a little [ __ ] now bill wants
to hand the ball back i want to point to
the crowd and uh no no i want yeah let's
let's wait till the season's over i want
to i want to supposed to finish strong
me a little stronger than you
uh you have a first pick because it is
an even weeks so you
it's in your hands sir
all right i want to ask you a question
why is green bay only a three and a half
spread against the lions
is aaron rodgers not playing
no because i think green bay is all
locked up
so what they could do is they could do
something where they play the first half
but then that that's what that's the
only thing i'm imagining because i don't
think they're playing for i think that
every the road goes through lambeau
all right so that throws the rest so we
have that's happening and covets
happening
all right i'm still okay should be good
i'm still taking green bay three and a
half they're still the [ __ ] lions
they played seattle last week that was
my big that was my gift of the week and
boy was it ever
all right um
[ __ ] man this is rough i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go with the
i'm gonna go with the [ __ ] early
saturday game
i i know man it's a lot of points but
i'm gonna take the kansas city chiefs
over to denver broncos even though it's
in denver and it's 10 points kansas city
is coming off that loss and i think they
could get a better seed i think they're
still playing for a seed uh that's why
the spread is that i'm going to take the
chiefs in denver am i confident with
that one
no
no dude this was a hard week because you
don't know who they're gonna sit and
then you got covered
you got all that stuff i'm gonna take
tennessee over uh
houston
i'll take that one whatever that spread
is i don't have it in front of me my
internet's not working but i have
tennessee written down oh tennessee
tennessee overuse it's 10 and a half
yeah that's a lot of points but i don't
give a [ __ ]
all right um
i think some guys on tennessee are
playing for uh
i think they're playing for next year
and all of that type of stuff
and i just think houston the wheels have
come off and everybody's doing the nick
van nexell come back to jamaica
what's old is what's new
dude the bills and the jets are a 16 and
a half spread
and i don't know why i want to take the
jets that is a lot of points i know the
bills really need the game
oh my god dude this is a tough tough
call i don't know if the jets are not
going to want to [ __ ] around because of
the draft pick
so i'm staying away how about that one
i'm gonna take
i hate to do this
i'm gonna take the baltimore ravens
minus five and a half at home against
the steelers i think the steelers won
their last game at home with big ben and
blew their load
uh the steelers need some things to
happen to make the playoffs the ravens
can make the playoffs with the win i
believe
i think i'm gonna take the ravens minus
five and a half oh i hate my first two
picks that's a tough game because i also
think big ben wants to go out if he can
[ __ ] the ravens one more time he's going
to do it all right paul i was so afraid
you were going to take the new york jets
because that's exactly what i'm doing
this is what i think is going to happen
i think the bills are going to go out
there they're going to go up big and
then they're going to take josh allen
out of the game and then they're going
to jets will come back and then [ __ ]
water whatever the garbage time horse
[ __ ] i just think uh
you know i'll i'll do 10
points
on the final week of the season but 16
and a half seems like a lot jets are
playing well and i also think there's a
lot of guys in the jets want to be part
of the rebuilt rebuilding program i
don't think the jets are as bad as
everybody thinks they are they're
playing some great football as far as
scoring points this month 16 and a half
points it's a division rivalry those
games are close
i love it i'm going to take it
hey man you're starting ah dude i'm all
right listen you know what you want to
do this last week
i'm going to take the indianapolis colts
minus 15 and a half
i'm going to take the indianapolis codes
minus 15 and a half against the hapless
jaguars to make the playoffs they got to
make it they got to blow them out big
i'm hoping that's a 27-3 game dude i
could be oh and three right now and just
[ __ ] i might have no no i didn't know
that to make the playoffs that's a great
pick or they they i don't know if they i
don't know dude this weekend that's a
great pick dude they're going to blow
them out that might be your pick of the
week i love that pick
um all right i'm going to take uh
i'm going to take the tampa bay
buccaneers
even though they had the uh
the unfortunate things there i feel so
bad for antonio brown and that guy
obviously needs some help here and i you
know i'm not gonna kick the guy when
he's down so
i just think the bucks tom brady does
not come out of the game
and i also think he understands momentum
and he wants to go in hard
i think that they're going to beat
carolina by seven and a half i don't
really love that pick but those are my
picks paul
and uh
you know i got to take a couple of
chances paul because i'm i'm on the
outside looking in this is yours to lose
paul you have the game on your racket
no man come on we're tied basically
oh by the way well you let me be tied
because i think ties lose and you guys
gave me that as a half a game but i like
the half a game because it makes it
exciting
by the way for the fans listening if by
any chance there's another nfl tie and
me and bill ty
bill will win for two reasons one
bill beat me in the head to heads and
two
bill has two four and o's and i only
have one four and oh so that's the way
that we're going to do it head to heads
and then let's say we tied on head to
heads who gets the uh unimaginable and
unforgivable you've had one unforgivable
and two unimaginables i've had only one
of each so in any tie bill is the champ
um my final let me go for uh
no that's right i have to go 402 sorry
go ahead
my
my final pick oh man there's so many
tough games
the raiders and the chargers and the
[ __ ] niners and the rams and those
games mean something
i'ma take the arizona cardinals
at home
against the seahawks
to get a i think it's yeah i'm going to
take the arizona cardinals at home
against the seahawks minus six and a
half
and um dude i'm scared of every one of
my picks i think i could go oh and four
i'm scared i know you were going to do
that i probably would have taken the
seahawks
you like to see
you lost
no both of those teams made me money all
year until arizona started [ __ ] in the
bed but
um
both of those teams were my old
reliables now i'm i'm staying awake i
was sitting there looking for both of
them this week and i saw they were
playing each other i just laughed going
oh my god oh by the way i got to give a
shout out to uh
somebody when i was out in arizona
alistair bure uh the drummer from the
legendary fanny band
uh all-female group
that the runaways everybody bangles
everybody every female group
gives them their props but nobody seems
to remember who they were um came out to
my show in uh phoenix arizona we hung
out we had her on efforts for family
season five them playing music and stuff
she hooked me up with a t-shirt
check this out
uh
what does it say fanny's back
www.fannyrocksfannyrocks.com
pick up your merch there and cds and all
that stuff that they have there dude one
of the truly great people
i've met i've hung out with her twice
and i feel like i've known her for 20
years just a really warm
amazing person with uh
incredible stories about doing the road
all right and she was on the third and
she was on thursday podcast several
weeks back so people can watch the
interview it was very very underrated
interview she was really really sharp
really funny oh yeah yeah yeah she was
she was right are we done i dude i hate
those pics i'm actually worried are we
done andrew
with the picks i mean yeah done with the
picks
well you were so worried about your
picks you didn't react to anything i
just promoted you just
no no
no she was still great
you're still thinking about arizona
no i'm actually i'm actually thinking
about that colts
15 and a half dude they gotta i love
that game man i love that game because
they they need to win
um
well listen no matter what happens it's
been the fact that we get to go in the
last turn
and we no matter what happens we beat
the book and i don't really take i'll be
honest you're there's a couple of guys i
live to be and you're not one of them
you're not one of them so i know you you
want to be talking about paul you want
to you come on dude i've already beaten
you twice how how good is that [ __ ]
merlot going to taste
and that stick
i won't of course i want to hunt but you
know if you come out if you come out on
top on week 18 you're not even going to
tell me
that you're not doing the iggy shuffle
in your living room i mean come on
because this is another thing too paul i
won the first two times when this league
wasn't televised this is the first time
i mean for all they know i'm making this
[ __ ] up this is inaugural yeah this is
documented paul
[Music]
martin loves the crowd come on by the
way if you go
if you go 0-4 andrew we did this we'll
do this next year
if you go all in for two weeks in a row
there's got to be some penalty there's a
penalty you only get to pick three games
the next week
you gotta wear you gotta wear clown
makeup the next week on air
yeah or a loser or a dunks hat or
something uh
all right well
instead of the turnover chain you have
though you have something along those
lines
no i get it we'll have like a turnover
change and then there's the picture of
the mush
his face is from bronx tail is hanging
off the end of it
all right guys those uh those are our
picks going into the final week of the
nfl season so please go to bed mgm guys
uh we it's working with them has been
great oh we got to do the monday night
special
monday not special
um when some money for you we came so
close last week paul
and we would have won people a lot of
money this week we got we're doing um
because of how the the schedule is we
are doing the chargers versus the
raiders
that line is what's that line andrew
that line is is it that line is three
and a half it's it's uh three yeah it's
it's three three even minus i hate that
game that's a tough game
yeah vegas
the chargers are minus three
both teams need it
um the under over was adjusted to
by the way bill great call with the 41
under for the steelers even with this
game and then in the end it only it was
40.
damn close
uh picking the steelers and then we had
we had uh we had chubs
running for a touchdown and we we
thought we had it twice and they uh they
stuffed them and then they threw it in
do you like the under over 43 and a half
for the chargers raiders
some reason i think that that's going to
be a wild one
i don't know why
over
yeah i think that's going to be a wild
one and i just uh
i do too i think it's going to be back
and forth
i see like a certain one
the raiders have a great front four
though man
that's the only thing i'm concerned
i like the chargers in the game i i
think justin herbert's coming off of uh
i think justin herbert knows what he's
got to do and i think this is going to
be his way to get into playoffs the
first year
i like them mine knows what he has to do
yeah the [ __ ] else would they have him
under center for paul
i think he's got to go out there ain't
nobody has to go
um sorry i'm holding my phone here my
internet's all messed up this week i
would say uh i i the thing that concerns
me
is as great as that quarterback is
justin herbert if he's playing on his
back
because of the raiders front four paul
let's think about this for a second like
i think you know derek carver's justin
herbert you got to give the nod to
herbert but like that front four
yeah
i mean look when's championship but does
it win in week 18
i saw some vegas guy and me and you
neither of us picked this game this week
but i saw the vegas guy on espn said
that the the amount of times the raiders
have covered or something like that
they're actually playing like a six week
win team and not a nine week based on
the spread
so that he's saying that they kind of
over achieved a little bit but
against the spread i don't i don't
understand what that has to do with the
human beings playing each other
i mean either that is such a stupid stat
i don't understand that on any little
dude against the [ __ ] what
yeah i don't i don't understand like
what vegas is what that sounds like to
me paul it sounds like analytics
yeah it's exactly what it is
yeah in the analytics say the analytics
say you defer and you give the ball to
the heisman trophy quarterback and the
alabama crimson tide so you can play
catch up for the rest of the [ __ ]
game and not kill field votes and go for
touchdowns and be down 24-6 instead of
24-12 so then some guy gets frustrated
in defense and knocks the guy's helmet
off and gets kicked out of the [ __ ]
game where the analytics on that paul i
ask you
by the way if you're a head coach of a
team
and you're in a [ __ ] tight game and
your player rips a helmet off another
player it costs you 15 and cost you the
game are you cutting the kid i might cut
the kid
no but it wasn't a close game pulp he
was frustrated should have been a close
game it should have been 24 to 12 it was
24-6 because they kept going for it
rather than kicking field goals in the
first [ __ ] half and second half
stupid
yeah that's why i like the chargers
coach because the chargers coach
actually kicks field goals when it when
he wants to get points but if you're if
listen your gut instinct was really good
with the under over last week if you
want to take the raiders money line we
could do that neither of us took the
game i like the chargers i would have
taken the charges but if you like the
raiders would do that
who won the first game
the first meeting
i think the chargers beat him hold on
i think the charges beat him hold on
43 and 43 and a half we're taking the
over definitely so the overworld take
we're taking the over and then let's see
what the charger schedule was
making money for you
let's see
let the monday night special
the chargers beat him 28-14 in the first
meeting
yeah see
low-scoring game for them wait wait that
would be 2814's 42 points
i just think that this one's gonna get a
little wild
yeah
raiders haven't given i like put them on
i like the i like the over and the
chargers to to win by three myself
and then um what did you say eckler to
score a touchdown eckler is that main
guy i hate this game i stayed away from
this game for a reason i can't get a
vibe on it
um
i don't think the right i love that
raider front four though man i love
those guys
all right listen we could roll with the
raiders
if you want to roll raiders money line i
mean we
i'm going to say the raiders and the
over
all right raiders over and eckler to get
a touchdown
all right we'll do that raiders over it
doesn't make sense because if you're
going to take the over you would take
the charges because they're a scoring
machine
no but the over is you're just rooting
for points we're just rooting for points
all right
you're right yeah we're rooting for a
shootout with the and we're getting
points so you know
i'm going to say the raiders
raiders and the over
raiders in the over and then we got to
do one more we'll do that kid eckler to
get a touchdown because he gets the ball
and that's just to get a touchdown right
no rushing nose just to get a touchdown
i love that that's in that's that's done
all right that's it there you go guys so
make sure you sign up with the uh
bet mgm app use bonus code bur
okay and we got offers for all of you
listeners if you haven't signed up at
seasons you go to the app you download
it you sign up with burb b-u-r-r you'll
get 200 free after replacing your first
10 bet and that's it just download it
and place a 10 money line bet any nfl
game 200 bucks uh and uh in free bets
immediately after placing your bet
regardless of the outcome just make sure
you use bonus code burr when you sign up
and uh even though our competition with
each other will be over we got the
playoffs uh we got the oh
wild card weekend's my favorite weekend
of the nfl my favorite [ __ ] it's there's
nothing better than wildcard weekend you
get saturday playoff games you get
sunday playoff games uh which team is
gonna be the dark horse that's my
favorite oh by the way i'd like to say
this before the playoffs start
eight weeks ago
i said
that i thought the packers were going to
go to the super bowl in the nfc and i
couldn't pick an afc because it was too
hard well guess what guys i got an afc
team i think is going to the super bowl
okay i thought about it
um
they barely they barely got in
they barely got in but i got a feeling
even though they digress i thought about
it that's my favorite thing you say i
thought about it
my pick for the super bowl is
aaron rodgers and the green bay packers
will be playing against josh allen and
the buffalo bills in the super bowl i
think the bills are going to catch that
late season stride after everybody
counted them out i think they're going
to eke out a win at the beginning of the
playoffs and go on a run you heard it
here i could be wrong but i i think the
bills and josh allen are going to do it
all right
so i don't i don't mind that i don't
mind that call i don't think there's any
really anybody really seems to be
standing out
well dude tennessee's 11 and
the tennessee titans and derrick henry
they announced is coming back for the
playoffs and vrabel is a great coach and
i didn't know that dude they're beating
up teams and and as much as i don't
believe in them the chiefs are still
there who else is in the dude you can't
count the patriots who's counting out
the patriots in the [ __ ] playoffs
dude you can't you absolutely can't i
just think josh allen and then
you're
i i just think josh allen and them are
are going to make a run dude who knows
i could be dead wrong they get knocked
out in the first round i look like an
[ __ ] but you know i like playing a
lot ago people would have said you're
crazy but now they're looking all right
i don't know the the chiefs i don't know
what it is they're just like uh
like half a beat behind the whole damn
year but i still
bill can the chargers make a run
can the los angeles chargers get to the
super bowl
no
don't count the bengals either
don't count out joe burrows the
receivers on the bengals versus the
bengals receivers are just
running
the afc is really just up for grabs but
i i i like josh allen and that kid digs
and i like that everybody's counting
them out i think they i i don't think
everybody's counting them out i feel
like they're the most stable of
everybody there
no i would say the most stable would
have to be tennessee based on
the way they play their record
and and
that was before i didn't i didn't
realize henry was coming back and you
were right i was i will say this though
um
you know
i can't remember what my [ __ ] point
was what the [ __ ]
i just said this big pause with the [ __ ]
well you happen to be you were right
about vrable i didn't realize how good
of a coach vrabel is dude that kid's a
good that guy's a good coach man yeah he
played for bill belichick i think he
knows how to
to do it but i i what the [ __ ] was i
going to say
about the bills or about i think it was
about the charges there's just something
about the chargers
that's why i asked there's just
something about him
the charger the colts make the playoffs
they could up they could upset somebody
that could take one of those teams out
this is all speculation yeah but dude
you're right you got the colts you got
the chargers you got the titans you got
the bills you got the chiefs
i mean there's uh it's who knows who who
knows where are we missing another afc
oh and you got the patriots
i don't think we i don't think we quite
have
we have enough to win a game i think i
think we're still but like you know
where we were at this time last year
like i'm loving where our our team is
but like
um
i put us some i don't know i mean i i
just think yeah we're on the lower
echelon of of those
i got excited there for a minute but
then
you know
you know we beat buffalo but that's what
i was saying so i stayed away from the
game the second time i was just like we
beat him the first time in a [ __ ]
windstorm it's like 50 knot wins
buffalo's kicking field goals that were
good they were getting blown off
just like that i mean that what is that
at that point yeah
um
the wind counted but it was like
you know what is it all right
but the fact that you guys are getting
annoyed with myself right now i'd have
no [ __ ] idea who's gonna win
um
on either side i'm not sold on anybody i
think more so than any year this is just
completely up for grabs and i like that
everybody's kind of counting tom brady
and tampa kind of out of it with like
antonio brown it's all disrupted
and all that [ __ ] yeah and then the
playoffs come
i'll give you a hundred dollars i'll
give you a hundred dollars when i see
you
if er i'll give you a hundred dollars if
aaron rodgers isn't in a super bowl this
year right when i see you i'll give you
a crispy one right when i see you all
right well what do i got to do
nothing nothing
not that's how confident well that is
going to be the most italian thing
you've ever said to me
[Laughter]
that [ __ ] bet is so stupid and so
about your ego i'm gonna it's not even a
bet i'll take it
andrew did you hear the dumbest thing
you have ever [ __ ] like i don't even
know why that came i love it
no it's that's how i like remember i
mean last time i just gonna walk up to
me like a doorman and [ __ ] goodfellas
and just stick a [ __ ] crisp hundred
in my shirt
hey keep the drinks coming hey the
irishman's here to take all your ginny's
money he goes bill goes what do i got to
do nothing
it's so stupid that's how confident
uh that's hilarious man um all right
well that's if you do that paul
we're taking video we're posting it on
the show
i will
whether i'm in los angeles or you're in
new york if aaron rodgers and the green
bay packers are not in the super bowl
there will be video footage of me
handing bill a crispy [ __ ] c note and
then we walk into a restaurant you think
i give a [ __ ] dude that's how confident
they're they are winning they're they
have everything i've never seen a more
complete i'm not even joking they got
the best one oh my god hire this guy on
espn you've never seen a more complete
team ever in the history of you watching
the nfl i've never seen a guy i've never
seen a team have both receivers and both
running backs with one of the greatest
quarterbacks i've never seen i mean i
think of john taylor this is my
comparison i think of john taylor jerry
rice
roger craig
i guess tom rathman even though he was a
thing and joe montana was the last time
i saw something
where no paul that's how you watch the
game and you're not gonna say anything
about [ __ ] ronnie lot
dwight kids i love what dwight hicks
no but i'm saying well yeah i haven't
heard you talk about defense at all i
think that hundred dollars is in my
[ __ ] pocket uh oh okay so you like
the bucks
no i'm i just like that hundred dollars
all right my [ __ ] i'm gonna start
wearing pockets paul that's how
confident i am you think i give a [ __ ]
wear one of those jackets with a zipper
here that's where i'll put it
all right guys this has been the uh mgm
uh nfl preview for anything better uh
going into week 18 enjoy the games and
uh we will see you next time
visit betmgm.com for terms and
conditions 21 years of age or older to
wager arizona colorado dc iowa
indianapolis louisiana michigan missouri
new jersey nevada pennsylvania tennessee
virginia west virginia wyoming
washington only all promotions are
subject to
qualification and eligibility
requirements rewards issued as
non-withdrawable
free bets or site credit free bets
expire in seven days from issuance
excludes michigan disassociated persons
please gamble responsibly gambling
problem call 1-800 next step in arizona
1-800-522-4700 colorado d.c louisiana
nevada wyoming virginia 1-800-270-711
for confidential help in michigan 1-800
gambler in indianapolis new jersey
pennsylvania and west virginia or 1-800
bets off in iowa call or text the
tennessee red line 800-889-9789
tennessee or call 1-888-777-9696
in missouri or 1-800
for washington that's 1-800-547-6133
sports betting is void in georgia hawaii
ohio and utah and other states
were prohibited promotional offers not
available in nevada
[Applause]
all right there you have it me and paul
verzi coming down to the wire paul verzi
coming on the outside like gangbusters
he is a half a game up on old freckles
who has won the jimmy the greek award
the only two times we've done it paul
verzi is trying to establish himself as
a winning franchise tune in next week on
the anything better podcast to see who
won
and with that we're going to listen to a
little bit of musical interlude picked
out
by um
andrew themeliss beverly hills his own
andrew themless
the greek freak and after that we'll
have a bonus episode of the thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast have a wonderful weekend
everybody and i will talk to you on
monday
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
january 6
wow
can you believe we're already 14 years
into this century
can you believe that you're going to die
this century unless they come up with
some rogaine for your [ __ ] heart
yes you are you are gonna die let's try
to call it right now i was born in the
year of our lord
so my goal in life is i'd like to see
the 70s again
all right
because the first time was just so
groovy man
sorry i'm [ __ ] punch drunk
uh getting back anyways
stay focused this week bill stay [ __ ]
focused um
yeah i'd like to make it to about
2072 i'll be 104 years old
you know
it'll be right before the dead getting
ready they're getting geared up for
another [ __ ] bicentennial
tricentennial is that what it's going to
be the tricentennial everybody and
they'll come wheeling me out he's so old
he remembers the second one
the bicentennial and i'll be like what
right
celebrating it was a hundred years ago
today that richard nixon
resigned from office
i get to watch that ship
the 100th anniversary of the
assassination of uh
[ __ ]
john f kennedy can i sound any dumber
and uh what else would i see the
hundredth anniversary of
of uh
the philadelphia eagles winning a
[ __ ] championship you [ __ ]
how the hell did you lose yesterday i
like the sinks
i like when they go marching in but you
know something versey got me all hyped
up that like the eagles were probably
the best matchup
for the seahawks
and to me i think the seahawks are going
to win the whole thing but there would
be nothing funnier if they didn't
i got money on them to win it but it
would just be [ __ ] hilarious if they
didn't
and then their fans had to go home the
12th man 12th man they have to go
[ __ ] home again
with that little [ __ ] piece of paper
on the wall
for their world record
the loudest crowd ever really you don't
think the arab spring was a little
louder you don't think that that crowd
was a little bit louder
running for their lives
um
after being dispersed
anyways what the [ __ ] am i talking about
here
um
you know i'm really getting tired of
people who don't live in the united
states of america talking about it and
then going you know and this is
happening and this is happening and i
just feel like people aren't even aware
of it
you stupid arrogant [ __ ] [ __ ] where
the [ __ ] do you get off thinking you
know more about
my country than i do i [ __ ] live here
why do i tell somebody in greece what
the i don't think anybody in greece
realized what's going on in their
country listen [ __ ]
from around the world world world we
know what's going on here
what would you have us do
protesters in this country are treated
the exact same
[ __ ] way they are around the world
if you're lucky all you get is the water
cannon if you're lucky only four of you
die from the rubber bullets
all right that's what happens all right
mr [ __ ] big mouths out there
all right you want to start the [ __ ]
revolution i'll i'll join it you started
you get on point all right there gandhi
you [ __ ] take the sheet off your
goddamn bed put on your [ __ ] sandals
and you walk down the street
i'll be right behind you in the masses
it's just and i don't think they're
aware of it oh with one more [ __ ]
douchebag
oh really is it really corrupt like your
[ __ ] country also
really are we starting wars because of x
y and z oh is that why we're over there
i couldn't figure it out i thought we
were over there making a [ __ ] dairy
queen thank you for explaining it to me
person from somewhere else
with your [ __ ] perspective from nova
scotia
[Music]
speaking of nova scotia
oh freckles is going to come to town
now what just happened to my computer
old freckles is coming to town i just
got my dates
um for the big canadian tour
for the big ass [ __ ] canadian tour
um i can tell you this
i can't tell you when it starts on march
1st and here's some of the the the
wonderful canadian
cities that i'm going to be heading
provinces whatever the [ __ ] you want to
call them
i'm going to be going there and then you
guys can tell me what's wrong with my
country and then say to my face that
you're surprised that i'm not aware of
it
you know like you don't think i have the
internet
all right uh
capital i'll be at the capitol theater
in uh
new brunswick
and
most n c
t o n new brunswick
that one starts that's march 1st
march 2nd
i'll be at the rebecca khan auditorium
in halifax nova scotia
on the 5th of march
i'll be in montreal quebec
on the 6th i'll be in ottawa
the seventh
i'll be in hamilton ontario the eighth
i'll be in toronto ontario
on the 13th i'm going to be in winnipeg
on the 14th i'm going to be in edmonton
on the 15th i'm going to be in calgary
calgary
gallery calgary um and then i'm going to
be in the 16th i'm going to finish it up
on the west coast in uh vancouver
british columbia so there you go
all right and i'm going to go up there
and ask you guys if you're if you're
aware of what's going on in your country
um
i'm sorry i know uh i know i know i've
been doing a lot of yelling
on this podcast and i i apologize i
apologize for my mood i apologize to um
oh i don't even [ __ ] know
isn't that what you have to do now as a
comedian you make a [ __ ] joke and
then you have to go out and apologize
every goddamn week somebody says
something somebody decides to take it
seriously then all of a sudden the
person has to apologize
you know
like they meant it oh you took it
seriously so i guess now i meant it
why don't you lighten up
why doesn't everybody just collectively
grow a tougher skin why don't you do
that well bill why don't you stop being
such a [ __ ] well hey that's a decent
point
that's a decent point
um
somebody asked was talking to me about
fat shaming this week once again talking
about how it's a terrible thing to do i
got to tell you something if you guys
want i love fat shaming
i absolutely love it that's how i stay
in shape
i fat shame myself
time i get out of shape i just stand in
the mirror look at you
look what you did you [ __ ]
goddamn pink pig what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you and i just trash myself i just
yell at myself
it's it's the weirdest thing to yell at
yourself in the mirror because you're
getting in your grill and you're looking
away at the same time it's [ __ ]
tremendous
it's like that movie face off except
it's it's all you
right isn't that what happened in that
movie
um anyways this is the monday morning
podcast uh i do one of these every
sort of monday
i like putting them out late just
watching people because they take the
[ __ ] name so literally you called you
[ __ ] what you called your tuesday
afternoon a podcast
you know when you went to the movie
theater to go see saturday night fever
on a thursday what did you [ __ ] [ __ ]
what did you call this thursday night
fever because it's thursday you can
listen to him whenever you want to i
have years of these [ __ ] things years
and years of ignorance i have recorded
go listen to a back one first of all
it's [ __ ] monday shouldn't you be at
work you [ __ ]
oh i'm on my soapbox this week
um
anyways
so i was flying back from pittsburgh
this weekend and uh
i had basically the greatest weekend of
my life
um
this is this is
how do i even start this [ __ ] i guess
i gotta start at the beginning of the
week
right why do i work my way backwards
what do you guys want to hear you want
to hear the [ __ ] show
into the greatest [ __ ] weekend of my
life or you want to hear about the
greatest weekend of my life and then
i'll backtrack into the [ __ ] show would
that make you feel better
i think it would judging by the tone on
the internet that oh wow bill had a
great [ __ ] time i should lead with
that and then go back to my and i should
end with my embarrassments
all right
so it lands softly and you can feel okay
at your plastic [ __ ] desk that they
got at officemax
all right
that's when you know you're not making
in life when your desk is made out of
plastic
all right
nobody ever sat
behind a plastic desk chomping on a nice
cigar
after making some [ __ ] zillion dollar
deal
that caused one-armed diamond diggers
to be a little further down in the mud
nobody's ever done that okay you want a
[ __ ] wood desk
that's made out of wood
in case i confused
you all right
and if you're sitting at a plastic desk
right now i'm not saying you're a bad
person
but i'm saying that you need to now desk
shame yourself
all right once you take out your little
compact
or maybe look into your little zippo
lighter look into your eyes and i want
you to find the sadness
i want you to look a little deeper and i
want you to see the dream
way in the back your eyes
and i want to know where it went
and when you're gonna bring it back up
to the [ __ ] front row
all right
now that might have sound [ __ ] but that
was supposed to inspire you
so right now i want you to slam your
fist down
on your plastic desk
until it [ __ ] shatters
and i don't know what else the rest of
the plan is
maybe you can get everybody else to
start doing it like a bunch of monkeys
you just start doing it and start
throwing your [ __ ] around the room i
don't know what
tip over your cubicles i want that for
all you
isn't it fun to scare people in suits
say you know something joe derosa never
picks up his phone
and now he's calling me
hey joey roses
i'm doing my podcast and unlike you i
actually pick up my phone you [ __ ]
pencil-shaped [ __ ]
hey let me call you after this hey this
is a great time joe now that we're both
living on the same coast
to maybe oh uh
let the listeners know that that there's
a lot of rumors
that uh that the the uh uninformed show
might come back together again
mccarthy mike finally bury the hatchet
that slag right with your tights on
i hope you guys could hear that all
right [ __ ] i'll call you later all
right
all right joe
um anyways [ __ ] jeez did i pull that
out of fourth grade recess hey dick face
um um
anyways
i don't know where to start all right
[ __ ] it i'm gonna go with the with the
most vivid memory this weekend i had the
greatest weekend of my life
uh about i don't know how many months
ago
the wonderful the generous
the always classy
and sometimes sassy
randy bauman from uh wdve and pittsburgh
pennsylvania
um who who basically he helped build me
in that market
you know i wasn't selling [ __ ] i wasn't
selling any tickets
in pittsburgh
and um
i think billy gardell told me about him
i can't remember how the hell the thing
went down but
he has got this great morning radio show
and he said listen
next time you come to pittsburgh
come in fly in on a monday night i'll
have you on the radio tuesday wednesday
thursday friday you run your freckled
face for the four days
and we'll we'll get you going in this
market he helped build me up
and all that type of stuff as if that
wasn't enough
so he turned that weak market into one
of my strongest cities to go to and it
is such a great city to go to as if that
wasn't enough
oh randy bauman called me up i don't
know how many months ago and he says
listen
would you be interested in doing
stand-up
at the uh
you know mario lemieux
has a a uh
a fantasy camp
and it raises money
for cancer research and all this type of
stuff it's just this great thing you
come in
you do stand up
you meet some of the guys he always has
some of the guys he played with they're
hanging out blah blah i was just like
yeah i was like absolutely that's all it
started as was just this little thing
and then he calls me back he goes hey
don't you play hockey a little bit i'm
like yeah you know i try i try it goes
way they have uh
you know the camp they you know
everybody plays hockey they get like
four teams they play each other and all
that type of stuff if you want to come
on
and play with one of the teams one day
you play with a penguins play and all
that would you like to do that i'm like
absolutely of course i would
so long story short
i show up
and uh
i bring my pads and i bring all the
stuff because i think i just think it's
just going to be a pickup game of hockey
and uh i don't know without getting like
tacky and just saying
all the stuff that they gave everybody
who
it's it's ridiculous you show up they
give you a freaking hockey bag
with your goddamn name on it
and inside there is all
all the
all the stuff
the socks the gloves the jersey a helmet
the whole thing
then all you have to do is just bring
your pads you're good in a stick and
you're fine and next thing you know
you're you're playing hockey way with
the penguins play
oh and you also go to the hockey game
it's too much to even try to describe
so anyways we do the stand-up show i
don't know who's in the crowd other than
mario lemieux and i don't want to know i
don't want to [ __ ] know who's there
because
because they're legends
and of course i go on stage i look to
the right and there's mario lemieux
sitting there it's like you can hide
when you're six foot six
and uh thank god i saw him smiling and
he was laughing long story short at the
end
at the end of it i met like
seven or eight guys that i grew up
watching
i don't know it was just it was the
sickest thing ever
i i don't know it was unbelievable
paul coffey
you know
other than bobby or the greatest friggin
defenseman of all time
theo fleury
brian trottier
it was it was insane
it was [ __ ] insane the whole thai
domey
that they were all in the crowd thank
god i didn't know
thank god i didn't know
jesus christ
it was my head's spinning right now and
and
we end up going out we're playing on the
ice trachea is our coach
lemieux is on the other team with paul
coffey
mark wreckie was on my team
two years removed from winning a stanley
cup i'm playing with this guy and i was
it was insane and then a bunch of
regular people actually everybody else
was better than i was but i mean just
we're all skating with them
it was insane
it was [ __ ] insane
um
speechless
i i don't i you know
i don't even have the only funny story i
can think of for the weekend because i
was in a daze the whole weekend it was
so awesome was uh
how awful i played
ah jesus christ it's [ __ ] brutal um
i really wanted to play a lot better
than i did i'm not gonna lie to you
and everyone's doing that no no you know
you were good for three years in you
were good i don't sugarcoat it i sucked
so i'm motivated
to um
i'm motivated to [ __ ] uh
to get better at that game so if i ever
get to do a play again i can actually
maybe handle the puck for more than two
seconds without it getting taken away
from me but uh it was just the best
the best [ __ ] time i ever had
and uh i still can't believe it happened
i was actually sitting there steve byrne
was the other comic on it i'm sitting on
the bench and he's playing defense with
paul coffey
and i'm watching paul coffey pass the
puck to my buddy
it was the sickest thing
it was the sickest [ __ ] thing i've
ever seen in my life
um yeah
so that happened
and uh so that was the great okay so
that was the great thing this weekend
dude ty domi showed us how he how he
would beat up a guy
a foot taller
he showed us his technique i'm not going
to get into it ask him about it someday
if you ever run into him it was [ __ ]
unbelievable
and they were all hilarious they were
all great guys
um
who else randy hilliard played for the
bruins for a while early on when i first
started watching the bruins it was it
was
it was insane
it was absolutely insane
um
i'm trying to make sure i don't forget
anybody
rick talketh jesus christ
he was skating by
eddie johnston
the bruins goalie who were one
in 70 and 72
and i was going i was like star struck
going i just read bobby always book
turned like an eight-year-old kid and he
goes i talked to him this morning i'll
tell him you liked it and i was like oh
my god he knocks bobby
it was just it was insane
the greatest thing ever
if you're ever gonna
do a fantasy camp there's no way there's
one out there that's better than the
mario lemieux one i gotta tell you they
it was a hundred percent first class
it was just the greatest thing ever all
right so that's that
all right
now
and right now i know i'm gonna get a
bunch of tweets going bill [ __ ] you go
[ __ ] yourself for having that experience
and you know what you're right i have no
business having an experience like that
thank you to randy bauman for hooking
the whole goddamn thing up
um
all right
plowing ahead here
uh what do i got here
let's do some advertising
do some advertising how would you read
some avatar how about you make an
attempt bill all right hulu plus
okay here we go hulu plus you've
probably tried hulu.com now with hulu
plus you can watch your favorite shows
anytime anywhere
hulu plus lets you watch thousands of
hit tv shows and a selection of
acclaimed movies on your television or
on the go with your smartphone or tablet
and it all streams in hd for the best
viewing experience with hulu plus you
can watch your favorite current tv shows
like saturday night live community and
family guy you can also check out
exclusive content including hulu
originals like the awesomes starring
snl's seth meyers and moonboy starring
chris o'dowd from bridesmaids hulu plus
also offers a great selection of
acclaimed films for only 7.99 a month
you can stream as many tv shows and
movies as you want wherever you want
right now you can try hulu plus for free
for two weeks when you go to
huluplus.com
that's a special offer for my listeners
make sure you use huluplus.com
so you get the extended free trial and
that they know that i sent you over
there go to huluplus.com bill now or
click the hulu plus banner on the
podcast page at billbird.com hey that
wasn't bad i only screwed up once
i was one over all right dollar shave
club
for a couple of bucks a month
dollarshaveclub.com delivers amazing
quality razors right to your door not
only does it save you a ton of cash it
saves you from trudging your sorry ass
to the drugstore for a pack of blades
personally i always get stuck behind the
drug addict who's going there to buy
some sort of something that he could
stick into his arms and some grapefruit
juice i don't know about you and it's a
pain in the ass but now with dollar
shave club for just a couple bucks a
month you don't have to deal with that
anymore why because amazing quality
raises will be delivered right to your
door that's right no more wasting time
and no more getting hit up for 20 bucks
every time you buy a razor it's highway
robbery everybody here meaning me is
getting that dollar shave club blades
and you should do it too and here's a
genius idea while you're at it try
replacing your old shaving cream with dr
cavez evie shave butter
from
dollarshaveclub.com trust me
your face will thank you later don't
waste time at the drugstore behind the
lady paying in pennies go to
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash bro go
to billboard.com and click on the dollar
shave club banner keep your stress level
low and your bank account balance high
shave time shave money go to dollar
shave club dot com forward slash burr
and finally
for the hat trick
legal zoom
you know people some things like
starting a business or protecting your
family
with the will aren't like your oh god
this first sentence of this copy it just
kills me
all right bill bird tries not to [ __ ] it
up take two two two
legalzoom.com some things like starting
a business or protecting your family
with the will aren't like your other new
year's resolutions you can't afford to
blow them off instead of less snacking
and more exercise put them at the top of
your list
what instead of less snacking and more
exercise put them at the top of your
list what the stuff i just read
now jesus i'm confused
let's start over again
legalzoom.com everybody some things like
starting a business or protecting your
family with the will aren't like your
other new year's resolutions you can't
afford to blow them off
instead of less snacking and more
exercise put them at the top of your
list legalzoom helps you incorporate or
form an llc
with their simple questionnaire starting
at ninety nine dollars over one million
entrepreneurs have done it and ninety
percent of
customers recommend legalzoom to friends
and family
you can also create a will starting at
just 69 bucks or even a living trust
quickly and easily get peace of mind and
protection no surprise fees no hassles
man no headaches legal legalzoom
step-by-step process was created by a
team of experts in law and technology
legalzoom however is not a law firm but
you but they can connect you with the
third party attorney and provide you
with any help self-help services that
you need
from wills to business formations
trademarks powers of attorney and more
go to legalzoom.com for even more
savings type in burr burr into the
referral box at checkout don't put off
things that you need to do today go to
legalzoom.com now and use the discount
code burr that's legalzoom.com discount
code burr b-u-r-r
jesus christ
[ __ ] butcher
um
all right so backing up a little bit
earlier this week
um
i did the new year's eve gig at the
wilton theater and um
right here in los angeles
and uh that's a theater that i've been
wanting to do for years it's just uh art
deco building it's just awesome i've
seen a bunch of great rock shows there i
saw
them crooked vultures
i saw when the last
shows of velvet revolver
[Music]
i just saw a bunch of great things there
i saw a couple i saw modern drummer drum
off there
what else
i know i've seen like 10 shows there i
can't really think of anything else
maybe some of them were like nia shows
who knows anyways so i finally got to go
down i went down there went oh i know i
went down there when rogan and stan hope
were down there
knocking it out of the park we had the
greg geraldo
benefit down there was just just one
that i always wanted to
to uh
to headline someday and i got to do it
and i did it with andrew themillis
jason lawhead and joe bartnick and it
was just it was just such an awesome
night [ __ ] great crowd
everybody seemed to have a great time
and
um all my friends had great sets and
bartnik went on
in front of me and was in a rare phone
was in rare form he he brought the
[ __ ] lumber that night
um
it was just an unreal night and then we
had a dj come out in the end i got to do
the countdown
took some pictures with some fans
afterwards it was just a great way to
start the new year so uh the next day
um actually later on that day because we
left about one two o'clock in the
morning
we went over to the rose bowl and uh
i was an absolute [ __ ] show this year i
am embarrassed at myself
i drank so much
usually i pass out during the game for
like five minutes and somebody nudges me
and i wake up i drank so much i [ __ ]
passed out at the tailgate
that's [ __ ]
i don't know what happened
i started hitting the hard stuff i
shotgunned a beer
all right for the first time in my life
by the way i never did it i never did it
because i was too afraid there was
always girls around i was like i'm gonna
do it and it's gonna go all over me and
nobody's gonna like me and i'm gonna
have to switch schools because that's
why my brain would work
rather than maybe they'd laugh and you'd
say something funny and next thing you
know you're having a good time with one
of the ladies
that's not how my brain looked
then they're gonna smash me over there
with the beer can and throw me off a
[ __ ] cliff like that's how my [ __ ]
that's how my brain still works but i
i'm aware of it now
and as it starts screaming and whining i
just there's another voice in my head
going no it's not it's not gonna happen
it's gonna be fine the light's going to
turn green and you're going to get down
the road there's going to be something
to eat you'll be fine
um
[ __ ]
jason law had
smoked a pork shoulder
and uh i have no recollection of eating
it
i don't even remember it
i was i was
i blacked out
ate a pork shoulder sandwich and then i
passed out
somewhere in there i shotgunned a beer
and then walking in
to the [ __ ] rose bowl i started
screaming at this girl who's like 23 in
cowboy boots
screaming you're not as hot as you think
you are to the point it got
uncomfortable
that's just [ __ ]
i vaguely remember that
vaguely remember that and they reminded
me afterwards and i have been
so [ __ ] embarrassed
so [ __ ] embarrassed this whole i just
you know like when you do something
horrible like that
i don't know about you guys but when i
think about it i ought like in my head i
just start talking out loud making
noises
to kind of drown out the thought i would
just think about and be like oh jesus
they're just
and i would do it like standing in line
with security at an airport and people
looking at me like now i'm like a
[ __ ] terrorist and it's like no no no
no i was a
scary drunk older man
to a 23 24 year old woman it was just
awful
so as always
i uh
i am on the wagon again i was on the
wagon until the [ __ ] hockey thing
this weekend okay it's not like
you know
when guys you grew up watching start
buying beers and [ __ ] you're gonna be
like clark [ __ ] gillies
sorry i met clark gillies last night
talked to him about his his fights with
dave schultz i got to do that
did i get to do it is it all a [ __ ]
dream i don't even remember so anyway so
i am on the wagon but i took two days
off
so
um
it was insane and i had like [ __ ]
three of those sandwiches
you know where they have the french
fries and the coleslaw in them on the
[ __ ] bread
we we closed down that place one night
me
steve byrne and [ __ ] bauman
and a couple other a couple other people
out just
closed that place
down [ __ ] burn was an animal man
every time we went we went to the
penguins game he ordered two of them
and then we went to the [ __ ] place
like the next day
after our show
i should really know the name of the
place it's like famous i i never
remember the name of the restaurant
he [ __ ] he ate two more he ordered
two and i ate half of his a pastrami one
with french fries and [ __ ]
coleslaw it was insane
and then last night they had catering
and it was more of them
and he just kept he can't not eat them
they're delicious
they make you obese they're awesome
they're pittsburgh it's everything
pittsburgh if you could make pittsburgh
and do a [ __ ] sandwich this is the
goddamn sandwich some of the best heart
attack food you'll ever have i would
actually
say that pittsburgh rivals chicago
chicago phenomenal phenomenal [ __ ]
heart attack food
just like
just that that city is just all you know
it starts tomorrow the diet starts
tomorrow i'm quitting drinking tomorrow
like like
the i if i lived in chicago or if i
lived in pittsburgh
i would be about 260 pounds
you know
and at that point you have to grow a
mustache
some sort of facial hair do you know
just to to just hide your big [ __ ]
face
dude what a [ __ ] weekend man now all
the shit's coming back to me
traject told the story of he scored the
fastest goal ever i actually watched it
on youtube when i was looking up his
highlights when i was going to go there
to do the show and i knew that he was
going to be there next thing you know he
was talking about it
and was standing there on a phone
watching it he scored in five seconds
and he's just
graciously standing there
like he hasn't won six stanley cups
talking to me like i like i'm [ __ ]
remotely on his level
greatest [ __ ] guys ever this weekend
he's telling me breaking down the whole
play
of how he scored in five seconds and how
it's only been tied he did it against
the bruins and it was just uh
what a what a [ __ ] weekend man
ah christ i'm floating here
um
so anyways
despite all of that you know what's
funny is i was eating those french fried
coleslaw [ __ ]
i almost said tuberculosis
sandwiches um
meat sandwiches
and the whole weekend though i was also
doing yoga every day because i was not
going to have my back give out on me
while i was out on the ice because i
already knew what my performance level
was going to be like so i kind of like
offset it a little bit but uh i'm
looking pretty doughy these days not
liking myself whatsoever
um
so anyways that that was basically my
weekend and then uh the rose bowl was an
absolute
it was awesome and i'm so pissed at
myself that i got that [ __ ] drunk
and i was belligerent and then also that
i i forget some of the best part and the
tailgate flew by and i have to wait a
whole another year next year i'm
drinking [ __ ] i'm drinking miller
that's it
champagne a beer i'm doing that they go
down nice and easy at [ __ ] seven in
the morning
kick a couple of those back when i have
an omelet throw the football around
[ __ ] tailgate like you've been there
before bill
you know i'm like at these [ __ ] rose
bowl tailgates i'm like charlie brown
every [ __ ] year trying to kick the
football and lucy pulls it away how many
[ __ ] years bill
one of them i was stoned sober
you know what's funny i don't even
remember that one either um
anyways but as always jason lawhead
rose bowl tailgate legend if you ever
are around that man when he's near a
[ __ ] grill
grab yourself a paper plate and wait
your [ __ ] turn cause that dude he
just keeps getting better at cooking
it's [ __ ] insane
i remember one point some woman walked
by and she looked at the [ __ ]
the uh the pork shoulder that he was he
was smoking
and she said oh that's nice
and i swear to god if i had a couple
more beers i would have tackled her
that's nice
[ __ ]
kind of understatement is that
i vaguely remember talking into a camera
[ __ ] face going did you grow up in a
city of gold
you know
[ __ ] nice
jesus christ i'm sure your mom was swell
um all right let's plow ahead here um
what else did i want to talk about i
didn't have a chance to watch any of the
football um and i apologize what i said
about the eagles i'm not trying to rub
your face in it did anybody see the
video where that guy
that eagle fan spit in that
saints fans face
um
i don't condone that behavior but
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
the other guy was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
jumping up but you don't do that there's
there's an etiquette when you go into
another stadium
when you okay you want to show up
wearing your your your [ __ ] colors
all right you know everybody's gonna
break your balls you go in
you [ __ ] roll with it you laugh you
take the [ __ ] and then
you show that you're not going to be an
[ __ ] and usually that works other
than
on like
in oakland san francisco
san diego or philly for some reason
i don't know out here you get stabbed or
shot or just it just it gets really ugly
um
and in philly you know i guess it gets
ugly too but it's not like there hasn't
been a bunch of stories about it
their team just lost in the playoffs
people look well he doesn't have a right
to cheer he isn't cheering
he's turning around filming sad eagle
fans walking out of the stadium
screaming who day
and all this type of [ __ ]
and i guess the dude i listened to it at
the airport was really loud i guess he
said i'm gonna spit in your face and he
kept doing it in this dude just [ __ ]
effortlessly
you know
fluidly as he was exiting the stadium
spit right in this guy's face and which
is a terrible [ __ ] thing to do
you shouldn't do it but it's one of
those that guy literally should just go
to central park at three in the morning
dressed like liberace jumping up and
down
holding a satchel of money
going look at all the money i got right
and then when he gets hit over the head
and mugged
right that's still wrong it shouldn't
happen but what are you doing
once you tie a big fat steak to your
[ __ ] stomach and a bloody steak and
go jump in an alligator infested [ __ ]
lake why don't you do that
and then i'm supposed to feel bad for
you when the alligator [ __ ] eats you
all right
um
that eagle fan was wrong he shouldn't
have done that [ __ ] but the saints fan
was was
reckless
with his own well-being
careless
sloppy
all right
if you were driving a [ __ ] boat you
would have run underground
because you weren't paying attention
you had no respect for yourself or your
own safety or the dryness of your face
in that moment sir
all right and he was not cheering he was
taunting he was filming eagle fans
leaving
screaming that who day all right he's
lucky he didn't get a bucket of urine
dumped over his head you do that in
philly i'm surprised you lived
so there you go so look up that video
and like i said i don't condone that
behavior obviously
but i can't judge it considering i
yelled at a young lady young lady in
cowboy boots because i was drunk
so now i am back on the wagon
all right and i reserve the right that
if i'm uh you know
if anything else like that happens i'm
gonna i'm gonna start drinking again but
i'm not i'm not you know like that
[ __ ]
you know i that
i give a [ __ ] how long you were sober
you would have started drinking too
[Laughter]
anyways uh what else in jesus christ
oh my god i i would say if i ever see
somebody with kansas city
jersey on or something i just give them
a hug but i wouldn't do that because
that would actually make it worse that
would be some sort of pandering
uh what happened to kansas city chiefs
fans should not happen to anybody and i
that includes yankee fans nobody
should have to [ __ ]
go through that
uh but that is today's nfl with the rule
changes you are never out of it
that was absolutely [ __ ] insane
i feel bad for chief fans and uh
i feel great for andrew luck because i
like that guy man i really think that
that guy is a uh
obviously i mean i'm not going to live
that guy
is showing
he's got that elway thing
he's got that [ __ ] elway thing he's
got a cannon he can run
he's never better than when the game's
on the [ __ ] line he's showing
hints of that
and uh
it's [ __ ] scary
the potential of that guy um
anyway all these guys cam newton's
having an unbelievable year
um did they play this weekend i missed
everything
i missed everything i was too busy
[ __ ] uh
having the weekend of my life i still
cannot [ __ ] believe that happened
i still cannot believe how nice
all the players were how gracious all of
them were
they they were just if they were [ __ ]
hilarious
just standing around drinking beers
breaking balls and then you went out you
played hockey with it it was just it was
[ __ ]
unbelievable
un un [ __ ] believable
i'll never get over it greatest [ __ ]
weekend in my life
um
anyways
so now yeah that's my thing i'm
officially [ __ ] old as hell 45 gonna
be 46 this year so i'm doing the i'm
hitting the yoga hard this year because
i was starting to have like i don't i
like i'm so old i like throw out my back
sleeping
[Laughter]
it's so [ __ ] humbling
you sit there and you lie to yourself
you know i look good for my age i can
still run around and [ __ ] and it just
you just can't after a while i don't
know what it is
how do you throw you back out sleeping
don't even [ __ ] say it's the mattress
i've been sleeping on this mattress
it's a newer one i've been sleeping on
it for a couple years it's still got
years left in it
it's me
oh jesus christ
i wake up in the morning and my dog
she does two stretches
up dog down dog and she is shakes
herself and she is ready
to go
she gets a yawn in there somewhere else
and she's ready to go and then she's
staring at me and at this point
she knows not to get too excited because
she knows the entire stretching routine
that i have to go through just to walk
her down the street
she gets excited
but then she just knows i have to i got
to do like this whole like this
six minute stretch routine
and it drives it drives her nuts trying
to [ __ ] remain calm because she wants
because she loves going outside like
every dog so goddamn bad
um
i don't know i guess i just i just have
to uh i just have to accept it and uh i
forgot to mention the the new year's gig
we got a bunch of emails people some
people came in from new mexico
phoenix salt lake city san francisco
portland sacramento
chicago san diego new york city
and vancouver man that's just
that's [ __ ] awesome man i i i and and
i got to tell you that
that was a great show that night that
really was a great show i'm not even
gonna lie i was uh i was on my game
everybody was on that game
uh if you came that night you definitely
got a uh
definitely got your money's worth and
i'm actually thinking about maybe
doing new year's in la every other year
because i you know
i get the new hour going where it's
supposed to be
and it's worth the money every other
year as far as like uh
if you if i just did your [ __ ] city
you know what i mean
if i come back a year later like half my
act still can be the same and i i [ __ ]
you over
so i do it like every other year
um
whatever i don't need to break down my
[ __ ] process i don't want you guys an
explanation
do i
i don't [ __ ] know anyways uh
where are we where are we in the podcast
here 43 minutes flying by here
all right let's get to uh oh here's an
email right here
conveniently enough about the uh the
wheel turn
uh billy wood
i was at the world turn last night
for your show my girlfriend and i drove
drove down from portland jesus christ
dude
take the five south the whole [ __ ]
way
uh we got tickets right when you
announced it because we knew we wouldn't
want to do
any of the traditional new year plans
dinner and parties and all that [ __ ]
they're all mediocre best but last
night's show was hilarious thank you
everyone was hilarious up and down the
funniest show i've ever seen we stayed
for the countdown and you didn't
disappoint oh it was great we had a dj
and i got to do the countdown
and sing that depressing song it was
[ __ ] awesome uh he said if ever the
end of the world is coming i'd want you
to do the final countdown before we all
burst into oblivion thanks again for the
laughs come to portland christ it's been
forever yeah i haven't been there in a
while thank you that isn't even like a
question or anything that was just a
nice email and i appreciate it
all right australia
uh hi i was wondering if bill will
return to australia i have a group of
friends who would appreciate seeing a
stand-up show thank you and kind regards
look how nice these emails are this week
i think everybody made a new year's
resolution to be a little nicer to me in
the emails
you know
maybe for once think about my feelings
uh yes
i was talking to my agent today about uh
putting together
a run through uh australia
and uh
yeah my [ __ ] goddamn phone never
stops
i'm definitely gonna do it i mean i'm
hoping to tour the entire country if not
i am at the very least i'm going to do
a number of cities
that is the game plan i'm hoping to go
from perth all the way across we'll see
what it looks like you never know what
um
you know when you're going to cities
you've never been to you don't know if
people are going to show up
you got to get a promoter who's going to
believe in you you got to get people
going to hype the show yada yada but uh
i really hope that uh we can put
something together maybe tack on new
zealand while i'm at it
we shall see we shall see but it's nice
to know that people are asking all right
long distance hiking now last week i
mentioned
that i went on a hike and we just kept
going and going like [ __ ] not
realizing that we had to walk back
hiking is not like a treadmill you don't
just get to step off and be like oh i'm
still despite the fact i walked for an
hour i am still only you know 10 paces
from my f the parking lot my car
we ended up going on like an 11 mile
hike
and uh
it was uh
exhausting to say the least so this
person is writing about long distance
hiking
another great old man thing to do yoga
hockey
ice hockey and uh hiking
you know
all right hey bill i've been listening
to your podcast long enough to know that
you love hiking you hate getting fat
and you get easily annoyed by day-to-day
[ __ ] i really think you'd enjoy
backpacking oh jesus
backpacking
i know it's awesome but can you call it
something else
backpacking i just feel like i'm [ __ ]
waiting for a bus picking my nose about
ready to get this [ __ ] kicked out of me
hey you guys want to go backpacking
it's a pack you put on your back
and you go backpacking
or long distance hiking okay let's call
it that
it's a really i long distance hiking
freaks me out because i feel at that
point you've walked long enough to run
into something that can maul you to
death slash rip your face off or at the
very least just sort of bite your throat
until it stops feeling the pulse
you know start getting into that next
weight class
of animals
i don't know you know mountain lions
black bear
grizzly bear
[ __ ] anaconda whatever exotic pet
that somebody let loose that has no
natural enemy that is now taking over
the forest
um
long-distance or long-distance hiking
it's really
it's really freeing to walk away from
civilization for a week or more with a
solid pair of boots and everything you
need strapped to your back dude [ __ ]
that you're more man or woman than i am
i i can't [ __ ] deal with that i get
scared
i get i get freaked the [ __ ] out i'd
have to be out there with somebody who
knew what they were doing who had a gun
uh automatic too not even semi-automatic
i need something that i could spray in
the general direction of the sound i
just heard and you know if we kill a
couple of backpackers
there's no one else around burying them
is optional
i would say leave them above ground
because they'll get picked away a lot
quicker then people will find their
clothes i guess the bones would be there
that's creepy see what happens when you
go out in the wilderness you start
[ __ ] talking about [ __ ] like that
i live in a suburb
okay there's plenty of people to shoot
and i never think of doing it they're
right out there
right [ __ ] out there and i never
think you're shooting them all of a
sudden you get me backpacking or long
distance hiking and i'm trying to think
how to bury bodies
all right every time i i
finish a long hike
i come back looking healthier and leaner
and feeling refreshed yeah because
you're out there eating berries wiping
your ass with [ __ ] pine cones
that's that that's why you have that
peculiar look on your face um no matter
how much you eat on the trail you're
guaranteed to lose weight if you spend
six hours a day hiking with a 35 pound
backpack there's no need to limit
yourself
to salads and juice i can't tell you how
many times
i've had
older day hikers look at my backpack and
tell me they wish they had done more
backpacking when they were able to it's
a really unique experience experience
out there on your own yeah i bet it is
well what can you please write back and
tell me uh
what you do about animals man
because i'm telling you right now i'm
not doing this
you know the only way i would do this is
i was in a [ __ ] platoon and we all
had machine guns just in case i missed
um anyways
oh here he goes he's going to calm me
down and it isn't nearly as dangerous or
as difficult as people make it out to be
if you stay on the trail you'll usually
run across another hiker every few hours
oh that's comforting
that's comforting every couple hours i
can run into johnny appleseed
but during the other hour and 50 minute
minutes i'm on my own
all right
uh you're running usually run into
another hiker every few hours that can
help you if you get hurt
and bears mountain lions and all those
other beasts kill a lot fewer people
than los angeles traffic accidents do
well i used to do a bit on that well
obviously because the [ __ ]
you know that this you're running into
one person every two hours sir let's do
the math here okay
here's the deal
there's like seven million people in los
angeles
okay
you can't [ __ ] go anywhere without
running into like a thousand [ __ ]
people out here
you're somewhere where you walk every
two hours and run into one human being
so obviously i can guarantee you if
those lines and mountain lions were down
here the death rate would be through the
[ __ ] roof
all right this is the guy this is what
he says to he goes just keep your food
away from your tent and you'll be fine
do you understand sir that you're
telling me to do something where if i'm
too near my food supply
i could possibly get eaten to death
you want me to leave my living room
you know why can't i just sit on my back
porch
listen i would love
i i would love to to
go hiking like that i i really would but
i cannot get past
um
no i don't think you should be able to
get past it that there's that type of
[ __ ] is out there
all right and if you get mauled to death
as a stand-up comedian
you really were just looking for trouble
weren't you
i i i that's you know somebody just
asked me to do a cruise
to do stand-up on a cruise and i i
told them i wasn't gonna do it
and they said why not and i said because
i'm terrified of the ocean
okay
that's why
i don't i i respect it the ocean is not
the ocean
it is the ocean but it's
it's literally
you're talking about
it's outer space on earth
that's what it is
okay you can't breathe in it
you're not you can't be in it
if you're in it too long you you're
either gonna get hypothermia or
something's gonna come up and take a
bite out of you to see if you're edible
or you're going to drown
those are your three [ __ ] options
and i know what you're thinking dude
cruz is just safe man you're out there
on this big [ __ ] boat yeah and until
you're not
until you're not
and then you proceed to die one of these
slowest most terrifying [ __ ] deaths
that there is
treading water in the middle of [ __ ]
nowhere
and somebody's gonna die no matter how
fast they can [ __ ] get you out there
somebody is gonna die and people follow
i [ __ ] did one cruise
in my life and i could not i couldn't
get past the fact that i was on
something that the second it [ __ ]
shits to bed and i know you guys think
that you oh i've been on cruises and go
[ __ ] yourself i talked to the band
that was on this cruise ship for [ __ ]
years and they told me stories
over a little [ __ ] plate of jello
late at night
those awful cruise desserts
some poor excuse for [ __ ] i i also i
don't like [ __ ] going out there and
all of a sudden it's maritime laws and
this douchebag who didn't even run for
office is now telling me what the he he
it's
whatever he says goes
with this stupid-ass [ __ ] outfit
go [ __ ] yourself
um
they told me stories
okay
they told me they told me enough [ __ ]
stories about food poisoning about [ __ ]
backing up about uh one engine not
working
and now they're going half speed and
then they don't make it to all the
cities and then they make up [ __ ] about
hurricanes and then they have [ __ ]
trust me
people having medical issues and having
to be [ __ ] helicoptered off
and flown as quickly as humanly possible
not to the best possible hospital to the
nearest one
all right and you're going on a cruise
they go all over the [ __ ] world
and they go by a bunch of [ __ ]
countries that you wouldn't want to
[ __ ] get ever have a goddamn hangnail
in but all of a sudden they're the
closest one and that's where the [ __ ]
you're going
dole hair dr harry hack it off [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
that all right
combined stand-up comedy in water world
i'm not doing it
all right so that's the thing about i
would absolutely love
to go backpacking i would love to do
that i would love to go up [ __ ]
mountains i would love to do that it's
way better than going to the gym
i understand 100
what you're talking about but
dude that [ __ ] where you run into a bear
mama bear and it just
turns around and just runs at you 35 40
miles an hour
you basically and you're sitting there
hearing this
this beast
like trees getting out of the [ __ ]
way
it's this thing is just coming flying
down the [ __ ] hill at you and you're
running
knowing you're going to get caught
and you're hearing your stupid pots and
pans clanking together
and all you're trying to do is just get
out in front of your friend
so he's the one that goes down and so
you can live
knowing for the rest of your life what
your strategy did killed your friends
hearing his cries
whatever the what is the sound of having
your face ripped off
now i like to lose weight like the next
guy
jesus chronic go out there with your
beer your [ __ ] bear mace
[ __ ] all of that
bears
mountain lions
poisonous snakes
what about if you just and then all the
[ __ ] varmints out there
i love that word because you sent me
sam's the only person i ever heard use
it and i when i found out it was
actually a credible word and not
something made up
i absolutely love that word farm it's
you know badgers wolverines
bobcats
people look at bobcats like they're no
big deal haven't gotten scratched by a
[ __ ] house cat
how bad that that thing can [ __ ] you up
with its little ass [ __ ] paws
all right
you you want a goddamn lynx jumping on
you
going to [ __ ] town because it's bored
or you freaked it out or you came near
to near something that it peed on
and you have no [ __ ] idea
that's another thing dude you're in
their world
this guy actually actually respected the
fact that i said i'm not doing it but i
also he i think he thought it was pretty
peculiar that i i wouldn't do a stand-up
on a cruise i just jumped subject sorry
and uh
and i was waiting for him to ask me why
and i would just be like well you know
would you do a podcast
you know in in on on a boat
in a lake that's full of [ __ ]
alligators
i mean you can okay we're on the boat
everything's [ __ ] fine but it really
is just an unnecessary risk
that you take it goes all the way back
to that [ __ ] saints fan
he got off easy
that same [ __ ] guy put that guy with
his jersey with his video camera camera
walking up to a mama bear screaming who
day who day and all that type of [ __ ]
he's worried about getting spit in his
face
he would have bare saliva all around his
[ __ ] neck
[Laughter]
ah jesus christ
i've actually thought about that like
what do i do if a bear was running right
at me i i just wish that i would have
the wherewithal to run right at it
like you know if a shark was coming at
me swim right at it and as quickly as
you can shove your [ __ ] head in there
and get it over with
that is the only [ __ ] strategy
we're gonna climb a tree
thing's gonna go right up that tree do
you ever see that youtube video of those
guys sitting in the tree hunting that
bear and all of a sudden the bear just
literally runs up the tree next to him
and is like
like i don't know seven feet above them
on the tree
next to them
leaning out sniffing at them trying to
figure out what the [ __ ] they are and i
love how the bears just instinctive
instinct really know it's just like like
with that bear
eight feet above you that's like when
you're in the upper deck of a stadium
you know and you're shit-faced
and you get into it with somebody two
rows behind you they automatically have
the advantage because they're punching
down right you're going to lose that
fight you're going to fall on your back
you're probably going to break your
ankle something's going to get twisted
as this guy's punching down at you not
just imagine it was a bear that was a
situation these people learned you got
to check out that video this [ __ ]
bear
it was on the ground and they're
whispering in their little fatigues
looking at this thing and then this
thing i don't know how it found him
you just heard
and that was it over this thing was all
of a sudden not on the floor of the
forest 20 feet down it was now eight
feet above them sniffing at them like oh
is that a food source
jesus dude you really just hit on like
two people today hit on two tremendous
fears i have being alone in the [ __ ]
wilderness and and and being out to see
[ __ ] both of those although i want to
hear the stories if you do it
you know not if you went on a cruise i
don't give a [ __ ]
going out there eating jello with your
date rape drug
[ __ ] weirdo
you know to go see the reunion of wham
cindy lauper cruise whatever the [ __ ]
you doing i don't know all right advice
on college selection
oh wait let me let me read the last
couple of [ __ ]
ads here
all right oh the classic here we go
taking it to the street stamps.com
everybody one great resolution you can
make for this new year maximize every
minute and every dollar for your small
business and you know what i know an
easy way to do that an easy simple way
what is it it's stamps.com think about
how much time you've wasted going to the
post office are you done thinking about
it
driving there finding parking standing
for a homeless guy holding the door you
gotta fish for a dollar pain in the ass
uh just use what you already have wait
stamps.com is a better way to get
postage just use what you're already you
already have your computer and your
printer to get official u.s postage for
any letter or package uh then the
mailman comes by and picks it up with
stamps.com everything you would do with
the post office you can do it right from
your desk there's no reason to go to the
post office anymore you can do it right
at your home for a fraction of the cost
uh with a fraction of the cost of one of
those expensive postage meters i've been
using stamps.com for i think two years
at this point
it's so easy so convenient even a [ __ ]
like me can figure it out so don't wait
uh right now go go to uh
use my last name bird to get this
special offer no risk trial plus 110
bonus that includes a a digital scale
and up to 55 dollars free postage don't
wait go to stamps.com before you do
anything else click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in bur
burr that stamps.com enter bur
all right who's next
who's next for the butchering e-voice
the holidays are coming that you're
still with this
this copy e-voice are you serious
e-voice the holidays are coming
everybody they're only 12 months away
and as a business owner you know what
that means crickets face it the next
couple of months
or 12 months
are the calm before the storm
now is the time to do something that
will dramatically help your 2014 e-voice
e-voice is the simple technology that
helps you make more money with e-voice
toll-free
uh or local numbers call routing tools
and a professional dial by name
directory your business will look like a
million bucks and with evoice you you
can't take a call
jesus christ bill and with e-voice if
you can't take a call
these saints will transcribe the
voicemail and email it to you so you'll
never be caught off guard again e-voice
has been saving companies thousands of
dollars every month making them more
efficient and more productive there is
no quicker or easy way to transfer
transform your business for 2014 and
with e-voice you can try it before you
buy it right now you can get a free
30-day trial to e-voice when you go to
or go to billboard.com and click on the
e-voice banner that's evoice dot com
slash billboard or billboard.com and
click on the e-voice banner now is the
time
to take charge of your business and
prepare for a productive 2014.
go to evoice.com billboard or go to
billboard.com all right that's the deal
that's it that's the advertising for
this week okay my apologies
to anybody who had to listen to me
butcher my way through that all right
advice on college selection
uh dear billiam bourbon i'm an 18 year
old senior
headed into my final high school
semester
and i'm conflicted as to what school i
want to attend after high school
i've narrowed it down to two colleges i
want to attend each polar opposites
jesus dude this is like one of the
biggest decisions of your young life
and you just heard me trying to read out
loud
okay so take everything that i say with
a grain of salt all right the first
this person is considering is the
university university of arizona the
safe
cheaper choice where all my buddies are
going to go and it's in it's in state
with about 40 000 enrolled students
i got to tell you right off the bat that
sounds fun because i don't like to read
i don't like to study i like to drink
with my friends and i like talking to
the ladies
so i'm already liking university arizona
goddammit that sounds like a nightclub
to me
uh they off okay they offer my first
choice for a major
what they offer my first choice for a
major
oh they offer my first choice for a
major which is nutrition and it's a
two-hour drive from home which is nice
considering my family is still mourning
the loss of my dad ah jesus dude i'm
sorry to hear that
wow all of a sudden that takes all the
fun out of this
uh the downside is that everyone from my
high school goes there and i feel like
it's
a cop-out choice i have a good yeah
i know what you mean
i know what you mean you know plus you
want to meet a bunch of a bunch of new
women
you know
plus you've got some shady past that's
always great to go to a new college you
just [ __ ] reinvent yourself
um
like hipsters try to do they trying to
act like they were the cool guy in high
school
that [ __ ] the cheerleaders you know as
they sit there dressed like robert
fulton for no [ __ ] apparent reason
anyways i had a good g uh good gpa
fantastic test scores and enough
extracurriculars to get me into some
pretty selective schools so i feel like
u of a isn't enough of a challenge i
don't really have much incentive to go
there and i fear i'll be unhappy
i'll be unhappy there due to the lack of
risk taking all right dude you sounded
like you may you're already making the
choice i feel you leaning
um you're jumping off sides here
uh the other is lewis and clark college
now jesus christ
a liberal arts college in a beautiful
part of portland dude you just went from
blondes and bikinis
to uncontrolled bushes
wearing bergen stocks now i know i'm
stereotyping
all right yeah jesus christ
you really are a smart one aren't you
now you know what okay wait a minute
i'ma stop being an [ __ ]
you know what university going to the
[ __ ] university of arizona from what
i've heard that's just like remember
that guy used to take those creepy
videos of the girls gone wild
you know
because girls got roofied was a little
too uh
on the nose
that's what those arizona colleges sound
like
um i had a bunny of mine from high
school he went out there and he got all
[ __ ] up it was it was too much girls
came to [ __ ] classes in bikini tops
what were you supposed to do
anyways he goes the other is lewis and
clark at least they did back in the 80s
the other is lewis and clark college
it's a liberal arts college in a
beautiful part of portland portland
oregon is [ __ ] gorgeous with about 2
000 kids
it'd be a nice distance away from home
and it's the college where my heart lies
well dude this is it right here
2 000 kids is great man
going to a school where it's a [ __ ]
city that they all have their own bus
system man that's insane
um just personally speaking he said it'd
be a nice distance away from home and
it's the college where my heart lies
yeah dude and you grew up in arizona
go see something different
uh the campus is absolutely incredible
and we have family up there in case
something goes wrong it's a tad more
pricey but my family set up is
my sen my family set up
to where i have the option to spend a
lot on college the downside is that it's
such a change for me a new city
i have visited
it but it's far away from home no high
school friends and i'm a natural
pessimist so i wonder what the gloomy
gray winters will do to me mentally oh
dude [ __ ] this man man up
you want to go you're scared you should
be scared you're 18 but it's it's good
this is a good thing to be scared of and
to get over you got to go out there dude
jesus christ
you live in arizona you can [ __ ] come
there anytime you want to
[ __ ] that go away to school man
portland is the [ __ ]
organs beautiful all the way up into
washington's [ __ ] gorgeous man
cruise down to coos bay i've been all
over that [ __ ] state
it's awesome and not only that you know
they got great college football up there
now
if you're into that type of [ __ ]
go to one of those oregon games i'd
[ __ ] do that in a second um anyways
i'll keep going he says the portland
weather is almost the polar opposite of
arizona weather and that spooks me ah
dude
rain doesn't hurt
all right you'll be fine
you know all right still i feel like
lewis and clark is the opportunity that
i've been waiting for plus i'm a
relative relatively solitary person so i
think i'd fit in with a more mellow
campus
than a fraternity run school like you of
a it sounds like you would
essentially it comes down to huge party
school versus beautiful small liberal
arts school
the thought of being alone with no one i
know in a new school scares me and
excites me at the same time let me know
thanks in advance go [ __ ] yourself dude
you've already made your uh decision
you want to challenge yourself it's
exciting you're going to meet new people
it's going to be awesome dude it's going
to be [ __ ] awesome
go up there have a great time and uh as
far as i know if there's a party going
on you basically have a party school
okay
and you don't want to all you want to do
is just [ __ ] party the whole god damn
time because you're not going to learn
anything it's going to go by like that
tailgate i went to and you're gonna be
drunk and belligerent act like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and come out of there with a big
booze head you don't want to do that
either um believe me
believe me
if you think that people aren't partying
in portland first of all if i had to
guess they probably make insane [ __ ]
weed
in that state
i don't know if it's legal but by the
time [ __ ] november rolls around it
probably will be
oh jesus i mean i would live there
i would live
in seattle i would live in portland i
would live in any either either one of
those states
more northern oregon or i would live on
the coast
it's just
some of the most lush
land you're ever gonna see with all of
that rain i'm telling you
it's absolutely [ __ ] gorgeous man
it's [ __ ] gorgeous
you know when the people are smart
you know reigns all the time they got
nothing to do with sit around and read
um all right advice
dear bilbo faggins now jesus he went
homophobic
i am taking an anatomy class before i
start the med school [ __ ] show
oh jesus all right there's this hot
chick that i've been dude this sounds
like the beginning of a porno you're
going to be a doctor in medical school
you're taking an anatomy class here
comes this hot chick and what she wants
you to help her out with the anatomy is
you take out your [ __ ] dick there
he goes there's this hot chick that i've
been talking to but i feel creepy about
asking her asking her out
while we're digging
out a dead grandmother's
fallopian tube together
who is probably a peach
dude i'm going to tell you right now
you're you're you're in the game you are
so in the game you don't even [ __ ]
understand it all right you're
you're smart enough to be in medical
school you're gonna be a doctor so right
there you're a [ __ ] rock star
to women
fail who doesn't want to bring him he's
in medical school he's got a mom and dad
i'm i'm dating a [ __ ] guy in medical
school and on top of that you're [ __ ]
hilarious
that's it one two punch it's over
up a cut to the [ __ ] snatch over
there
um
he said how should i approach this
by the way when are you going to come to
san francisco with gingerly love
um
let's see here how do you approach it
well dude you're
well you don't have to hit on her while
you're working
how about you're in the when you're in
the lunchroom
uh like dude you're already
you're so [ __ ] in there it's
ridiculous you're already funny as
[ __ ] hell so i have total faith in
you all you all you need is a location i
would say yeah when you're not standing
next you know digging into a cadaver
other than that you know
just start working on her
work you know make her laugh at work ask
her about her background but blah blah
blah you know
but don't [ __ ] you know talk to her
too long before asking her out
you know work the body a little bit hey
where'd you grow up how many brothers
and sisters you got blah blah blah blah
and
you know i don't know ask you seeing
anybody
would you like to [ __ ] see me can you
[ __ ] open your your lab coat with
nothing underneath it
you flash her
you can get away with it you're in
anatomy class bang that's how you do it
now
um dude you're going to be fine you
don't need my [ __ ] help
all right
just don't do it when you're dissecting
[ __ ]
all right jesus christ is that guy
[ __ ] killing it or what
don't you wish you had his life
if you could do it over again are you
smart enough to get into medical school
and there's some hot chick in your
[ __ ] class
jesus i can tell you this sir she's
going to be the first of many
all right you [ __ ] all you got
to do is walk around with that
stethoscope around your [ __ ] lab coat
with your scrubs on forget it
it's going to be raining hailing
[ __ ]
johnny blue top shelf
[ __ ] [ __ ] for you good good on you
good on you sir you studied
you studied in high school you deserve
it or you [ __ ] uh you were born with
the a brain you got the a brain
ever tell you about that my philosophy
some people get the a brain some people
get the b brain
some people get to see brain and then
after that i don't i don't make fun of
people
all right i make fun of this the sea
brain
the sea brain is is that person that you
know
you know you know those mouth-breathing
[ __ ] morons
those people all right
they got the sea brain
that one where they can get a driver's
license
you know
they can pour themselves a bowl of
cereal but and they can get to work on
time
you know you know those people like when
you ask them a question they get a look
on their face almost like they're going
to start crying that would be the sea
brain
the b brain
would be
would be me
you're smart but you're a [ __ ] idiot
[Laughter]
and then the a brain
is you just you know just straight
across the board your number one draft
pick
all right
i would go late in the third round but i
got a lot of hat
all right the campaign voice built
uh we're gonna get america back to work
and it's time we give tax cuts to people
who
who really need them had me rolling when
i first heard you do that stereotypical
campaign voice you know what's funny i
don't even know
what voice that is
i remember saying that stuff
how do i i don't i'm thinking like i
don't yell do i i don't [ __ ] know i
can't remember anyways i've heard you do
the campaign voice a few times on conan
opie and anthony etc
do you do that in your act or was that
just something you did during the
presidential election season
it must have been because i can't
remember how to do it
oh this is [ __ ] killing me
do i do it my am i do i do i have a
funny voice that i'm not utilizing that
could get me another [ __ ] desperate
six minutes to my act
uh would you do a few minutes of it on
your next podcast
what am i a [ __ ] jukebox
listen i'll do it for you but you got to
send the audio of you doing your
impression of it all right you got to
make an ass of yourself and then i'll
[ __ ] tap dance for you
um thanks he says thanks i've been
paying attention to your comedy since i
caught your half hour special when i was
in middle school
i'm now 47 no kidding
i'm really happy for all your success
and i wish you continued success jesus
christ people are coming out of the gate
in 2014 really nice thank you very much
sir
how do i do that thing
how do we do the campaign voice that's
not the one that
absolutely
just like was was it that one now you
got me in my head
see i'm i'm i'm smart but i'm a [ __ ]
idiot i can't even remember the [ __ ]
that i do
ah [ __ ]
anyways
here's the wrap up everybody now that
the show is over don't forget to sign up
for your free trial of hulu plus who the
plus lets you binge on thousands of hit
shows anytime anywhere on your tv pc
smartphone or tablet support this
podcast everybody and get a free trial
extended free trial of hulu plus when
you go to the podcast page at
billbird.com and click on the hulu plus
banner or go to huluplus.com
bill that's huluplus.com bill
there you go um all right that's the
podcast for this week and um once again
from the bottom of my heart
thank you to randy bauman for hooking me
up
with the uh
the gig thank you to mario lemieux
and all everybody at the camp everybody
that i played with everybody who laughed
at the jokes from me and steve byrne
told him um i don't want to speak for
steve but i think i can that was uh
we were just shaking our heads today uh
we flew back we connected in dallas and
we got uh
um they would de-ice in our plane so we
missed the connecting flight and we got
stuck there for a couple of hours
um those you follow me on twitter i was
twittering my [ __ ] misery when i was
there
um until i saw the guy with the neck
brace sneeze that [ __ ] killed me
the look of panic on his face because he
knew he was gonna sneeze and he knew it
was gonna hurt
i if i could ever if i could do that
face on cue i swear to god i could win a
[ __ ] oscar
um but anyways we were sitting there in
the uh in the airport just talking about
just talking about how
just shaking our head
it was unbelievable as always you know
i'm not going to name names and all that
type of [ __ ]
um
but it was it was [ __ ] amazing man
[ __ ] amazing so uh that's it man
that's my that's how my 2014 started
and um people actually have pictures of
me now wearing pittsburgh penguin jersey
that's the only thing but i was willing
to pay that price
uh i got to thank ty domi for punching
off samuelson in the face
it's just how do you [ __ ] beat that
how where does 2014 go from here